feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump day hump
someone you love or someone you don't
love you know it is Wednesday September
somebody clear unclear and you know what
doesn't matter because it's Wednesday
and it's just garbage it's Wednesday and
we are really slowly falling into fall
like I checked my weather every day now
I don't know I think that's like part of
getting older it's like you started
hiding your weather and we are in the
60s like all day whereas we were in the
70s before so slowly we are creeping
into fall and I'm really excited I know
you're falling into fall but I've been
like sleeping and fall for a good month
I know but like you've been like back
and forth shorts jeans shorts that I
have been pants every day you know what
you haven't I've been smelling you you
haven't gotten your makeup a sentence
right I have it I definitely am NOT so
like you think you're falling into fall
but there's a lot more work to be done
okay I feel that but the weather is
changing and so are we
I mean I'm still wearing shorts but I'm
pairing it with a chunky sweater whoo
you know are you Jax Taylor cuz that's
one mighty chunky sweater a little
housekeeping announcement
this is Jackie and eyes last episode
together in studio this week very sad or
at all this week oh that's true because
tomorrow I will be replaced by the one
the only NIC vial who will be filling in
for me and who will be recording an
episode of the snatcher with us right
after today so if you're just looking
for content there's tons of Voucher
recap we'll talk by the Batchelor little
because so much happens yeah and it's
you know it's crossing over into pop
culture that's true it's posted so then
Friday me and martyr we're gonna be on
tour we will record an episode I think
on Friday we'll be in Seattle
I've known whatever you should record it
from the market okay I shouldn't take
some pictures there yeah we never leave
the hotel room like wherever we go so
I'll be sure to take a picture of it
inside of my eyelids to be the entire
time I'm always so tired on tour people
like did you go see you know the money
man I'm like cow is amazing
in America whatever I'm again no I
didn't leave my room once so me and my
girl headed to Portland today I've never
been we have a show tomorrow night
tickets available girl [ __ ] calm and
then Friday night we have a show in
Seattle sold out sorry nothing I can do
about that then we have the day off and
we're heading over country lines you
need to fill out all these people were
cuz we're like going to Vancouver for
work course yeah but it's like we're not
flying we're driving so it's just like
we're gonna go to the border like you're
driving are you gonna take an uber to
another country no no we're a car
service
could you take an uber to Canada that's
what we're doing it's like an hour and a
half drive from Seattle
it's crazy cousin doesn't that bridge
driver has to have his passport on him I
don't think it's so simple but it's not
an uber but I call them in but now I'm
saying like I'm have you taken over to
Canada I mean I think okay so when I was
just in Vermont this part of Vermont
that I was in as like a popular vacation
destination for people who live in
Montreal because it's so close to the
border like we were driving to her house
and like literally it said Montreal this
way so I'm thinking maybe like in that
circumstance you could take an uber it's
like a twenty minutes but maybe like
we're dry really drops you up at the
border because he probably doesn't have
his passport on him and then you've gone
now to get an American name you're get
another uber yeah yeah that's an
interesting call you know I didn't think
about that
we should figure that out yeah you've
been very laissez-faire with the travel
accommodations he's been French camper
about it yeah well she's influencing me
so heavily these days French campers the
devil don't you think so counselor she's
insane yeah she starved us out the other
night tickets are also evaluated at my
Vancouver show guys I'm trying to thirst
like tickets are also available to my
Vancouver show WWE our job calm can't
wait to see you my first trip to the
west side west coast yeah but remember
we said it's on the coast so Oh true the
west side you've like been on the west
side before actually that's so nice I
did a show yeah I know I did I did
look three shows in California so I know
but the California and Oregon are quite
different you know you one would think
but they're quite close to each other
know what talks about like the vibes
like The Oregonian knives I mean I want
to go to Forks Oregonian is that we're
going on my girl we're going to Seattle
and we have to hit up Forks is it a real
place yeah and you're also going to
Vancouver so you should go like watch
Riverdale that's a nice okay so I TM dry
to Ross and I was like I'm gonna be we
have a day off on Saturday okay I need
an answer did he see it uh you know I
never checked up hold on you miss Isaac
to go to pops I would die I might come
eat you know I know that would be crazy
writer Ross that doesn't work out like
so many other folk scene [ __ ] brood
shell-shocked
I think film hallmark movies there I
watched a hallmark movie last night with
Jerry O'Connell and Rebecca Romijn a bit
so cute yeah it was a really really cute
movie and you know how when you watch a
hallmark movie you're like oh my god how
are these two people not loved in real
life like yeah it's all there the
chemistry you didn't have that like
sense of longing it was really a nice
thing they should do more couple a
hallmark movie if you watched our
patreon episode of our behind the scenes
in Austin you'll know that when we were
in the Austin Airport stranded for eight
hours we came in contact with the most
amazing machine ever called the bros yo
and it is a coffee vending machine and I
don't really drink coffee but Olivia got
something that I tried and it was heaven
on earth actually Marco got it sorry and
so I tried to replicate it this morning
I'm not a coffee girl I never really
drink coffee energy has never been like
a problem for me but I got this iced
caramel macchiato right nice latte
caramel macchiato and I got it today at
Starbucks and it's no bro geo bro go
what would this rig oh here we go it's
so briga but it's making me feel like I
have to poop so I've ever done run out
of here that's why I also Starbucks
coffee really does that to you yes the
[ __ ] devil's workshop and you know
what I'm such an experienced like coffee
drinker I was just like in the back of
my bird today like sipping my coffee
like a girl you know like a real girl
yeah and I can't even do that I spilled
all over myself literally my entire
shirt think on this shirt is cheap it's
made of like you know those things where
it's like stains just like slide down
they don't like said it was nothing Yeah
right no it's like a microfiber couch
very cool yeah very very cool yeah no
part of the art of drinking coffee is
like learning how to control your bowel
movements because you can't just like go
when it hits you oh my god I know and
you know what like I've never been one
who has like good bowel control know you
like even on this show like when you
gotta go you gotta go
yeah actually you know what's so weird
like when we were doing the breath like
once a week I would let me have to run
off and like [ __ ] my pants I don't
really have that well now that I said
that I will but nobody went like you
could but you're just more professional
now you know if you take this more
serious diarrhea knows no
professionalism like wait just I Osteria
know like there were a couple times like
on the toast where I would like run the
bath for the runs yeah
rats are yeah you've done it like a few
times I've done it like twice yeah I
don't recall it happening so often at
the breath but I don't know it did well
I'm glad to see you're feeling better by
the way I'm so annoyed that we didn't
acknowledge it because we probably don't
realize but like last week we had our
300th episode of all time yeah I mean
because let me tell you I saw Tanya rad
and Becca Tilly was celebrating their
100th episode I'm like oh man that's so
cute I wonder how many we've done and I
went to our like back-end podcast and it
said all episodes one of three or four
it's more than that because we started
uploading our podcasts like last
September to that platform but before
like from April to September of last
year we were doing it on soundcloud so
what's new but the RSS feed I think
pulled all of them I don't think it's
more than like we're genuinely curious
like go to UM go to iTunes and then we
have this season plus last season like
at this season we're at like 160
episodes or something like that you know
April 4th you know all of our episodes
are around here yeah the first one April
4th
so this is like our 306 episode oh I
would celebrate now we have to wait till
for I saw they were at 300 episodes and
I was like that's nothing no they were a
hundred oh but they do weekly we do five
times a week yeah okay and then maybe
with all the patreon right like 350 yeah
with this naturally Oh 63 I'm so today
like today is the day the snap okay I
know can I also just say like how really
proud of us I am like we said we were
gonna do it and we did it you and I both
said like we can not take on another
podcast like we can barely get our own
podcast off the ground and we just did
it because there was so much demand for
it and yes I did miss last week but
before that we didn't miss a single beat
I know and I just want to say how really
proud of us I am yeah and now we have
premium guests coming on like we have
the best host in the world the Sinatra
was included in bustles roundup of top
ten bachelor number you were number four
please that's amazing yeah and Jackie
wire who bustled for respecting the hell
out of the morning shows and the snaps
and the snatch oh it's not sure like
needs more respect and she's getting it
today but we know the snatcher is
getting like full rejection it's a lot
of eight I also need to commend you on
running The Bachelor the snaps or
Instagram like Bachelor drama never
stops and you are always [ __ ] on top
of it and last night you revealed to
sure was and you did it in the best most
respectful spoiler-free way for West
Coast teens I just would say if you're
not about following it's underscore the
Snatcher which we have to take care I
know you should be because it's all the
drama with like the new girl you're
really keeping me upset even me young
and the snacks lair like she's so savage
like she doesn't care what other people
like other like bathroom people
contestants like seeing the post like
she doesn't care she says what she wants
and she posts that she's not here to
make friends
she's not here to make friends with any
of bachelor nation follow you I want to
say I think Amanda and Lauren Amanda
Stanton does I think Lauren Bushnell
does but they follow it from before yeah
I don't know that it's the Commission
still active though on it oh my gosh
Nelson is so supportive yes she's a
woman who supports other women she
really is like she is like what Taylor
Swift is talking about yeah I could see
them being friends actually me too I
could feel like Taylor spoke with love
chin chart kids and charm chins and cars
I wonder - Taylor watches The Bachelor I
feel like it's so her vibe I actually
feel like it is - and now that Gigi is
involved I think so I could see her like
having wine night with her friends and
she makes them over and like bakes
cookies maybe gigi hadid was eating a
toast with cookie and a glass of wine at
Taylor for his mom's house while she saw
Taylor she and Taylor was like you
should go for it and like when we talk
about Gigi hanging out with her friends
like that like it's Taylor and Taylor's
like so you know like Taylor's hope I
just read her Rolling Stone article like
her whole message it's like you should
be able to have a personal life so she
was probably really encouraging of Gigi
but you don't just go for it like [ __ ]
what everyone says a hundred percent and
look they're so happy I know Taylor is
just making people happy left and right
okay well we will bring this all to the
snatchler later but I do want to talk
about because it's not part of the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
Taylor's article in Rolling Stone oh
really
oh no it's not because I didn't have a
chance to read it so all I saw was the
cover where she's bringing back very
light eyebrows just want to say funny
like that's what you see at Liberty and
even I know that eyebrows yeah because
they're not there eh-eh so yes she's on
the cover of Rolling Stone awesome she
was on this 2012 it's a very long
interview I think I got like 75% of
getting through this morning like
couldn't you've released it last night
so like I would have had the time but it
was very interesting I know everyone's
like really sick of hearing her talk
about like all the drama the Kanye but
at the end of the day like so many
people were talking about her
and about that situation and she never
really got to address it so I know no it
seems like a moot point now but it's
like it's the first time she's really
ever speaking about it and she dropped
some very interesting factoids about the
Kanye thing she's got a carrot people
think it was like this 10-second
conversation and like that was it and
she's like there were so many things
that led up to it and I definitely
overreacted but I was like so over the
situation like basically he called her
for like an hour was literally begging
her to uh introduce him at the video
Vanguard Award and she was like really
like not into the idea but she was so
she was like I just wanted him to
respect me and he was we were going to
dinner I'm like we were having private
conversations and he was finally giving
me this respect that like the insecure
19 year old me like really craved and
she was like it's so sad but like that's
all I cared about like he was just so
dismissive of me and like now he has
finally given me a respect so just he
was trying to make this like friendship
happen she like wanted him to think she
was cool you know hundred percent and
she was trying so hard to make it happen
and she said she would do it and he gets
I didn't even realize it at the time he
gets on stage and he's like MTV got
Taylor Swift to introduce me they wanted
those ratings and he was she was like
I'm literally standing in the audience
with my arm around his wife and that's
not what happened and she was like it
was in that moment I realized he was
really to face like he can she said he
could be so super sweet and she said he
used to say the nicest things about my
music and finally I was getting that
respect that I like was so insecure
about and then he would just do and then
member when he sent that the huge like
oh yeah flowers you would thought it was
like thanks for introducing me but it
was actually an apology he knew that she
was mad at her for like saying that when
that's not actually how her introducing
him so she was just really like over it
and she but she was for so long up to
that was really trying to like make this
friendship happen and then she said it
was like an hour-long phone call Kim
only posted the 10 seconds no Kim posted
a lot of it it was more than 10 seconds
but she did she didn't know I think me
and Taylor might still have sex and she
clunk she said she she clung on to that
made damage famous but at that point she
was just it was like a cycle of events
where she was like I'm [ __ ] like I'm
I don't want to be friends with this
with this person anymore
and then what I thought was the most
interesting part was like she took
through like three years off where she
didn't talk to anyone and she was like
she didn't have internet access like she
said like she's like there were things
happening that she literally knew
nothing about like for the first time in
her life and how those three years were
like so tough but it was like the best
thing that ever happened to her but you
always remind like that's how we feel
about being canceled but yeah the worst
thing that ever happened to me but
so the best thing and she spoke about it
in such an eloquent way I was like yeah
that's how I feel too like she was
literally like saying what I say wanted
to say but like in a smarter like more
eloquent way it was a really good
article she spoke a lot about Scott
Borchetta he was like the art the
interviewer was like is it true that you
didn't want to play the parkland
remember has got me asked up or said it
was like she got offered to do parkland
what end one love one love Manchester
and she was like my team knows if
anything is ever brought to us by
Scooter Braun don't even bring it to me
so Scooter Braun and ariana grande were
there parkland and the one loved
Manchester concerts so Taylor says that
it was never even brought her because
she would never in her life work with
Scooter Braun that's what she said which
actually I do believe I believe that too
but that's actually like did I make that
wish that'll look bad no but I actually
like I just assumed that like that can't
be true like she would never turn it
down like I guess technically like it
was brought to someone on her team who
did not bring it to her yeah because
like that wasn't even a big enough thing
to for her to overcome her hatred of
Scooter Braun yeah which Niki would
think it would be he would think it
would be agreed but interesting just
lots of interesting factoids it was a
lot of she always does really well in
those articles they really humanize her
oh and what she said which was the
majority of the first half of the
article was like everyone just like
hating her like and she knows that likes
you that I can't fire without someone
being like it's now you know like
everything she does she's like when I
try and do charity it's not good enough
it's when I'm trying to be brave so that
was really interesting just her hearing
her talk about how like and and she went
through that as like a teenager and I'll
be at the teenager who was like very
stunted just because of like the life
that she had and she's extremely
self-aware and she said something so
smart she was like and when I get all
this credit chris is I'm sorry I was
like what is the noun of critical when
she gets all this criticism she's like
she wants to like dismiss it but she
hates people who can't take criticism so
she tries to be self-aware and
internalize the criticism even though
when people criticize her for like
seemingly no reason like how can you
internalize that and try and like make
yourself better when like she's just
doing charity and someone's saying it's
insincere you know yeah there's like a
fine line between taking criticism and
just like you know or not anyone being
hard on yourself he's incredibly hard on
herself like the article was like really
funny at some points like really sad at
some points like how much thought goes
into
early like one decision is like sad yeah
I agree with that okay I'm excited to
read it yeah it was really good there's
a lot about politics it was a lot about
lover there was a lot about Kanye really
a robust article well you know I feel
for her because I feel like she can't do
anything right
whether she does this or that like
people will say and if you like she sees
all these artists like coming up who
everyone loves
yep you know like to the cardi B like
yeah but you said something to the legs
barn about flagpole yes she was like
everybody loves something new like they
raise your flag high and they're like
yes yes and then like this flag has been
up for too long like and there's a new a
better flag and then no raise and but
then you take some time off they'll
start to raise your flag and and nobody
likes anything that's universally liked
and people look for any reason to take
you down at that's at that point when
they're trying to raise a new flag you
know ya know but it's really it must be
like frustrating to see but I I feel
like she'll in time it comes for
everyone so it doesn't bother her
because like their time will come to now
that I want other people to be taken
down but it's like frustrating when
you're at that level that you can't do
anything right and then also one that
lasts very interesting thing as she was
asked about the girls squad and she the
guy was like did you think that it was
gonna take on this like caddy like high
school clique thing and she was like
honestly no like the metaphor we were
trying to put forth is like people
always think like girls are friends
until and the bit but they all have
knives in their pockets like they'll
take a picture together but they
secretly hate each other and what I was
trying to do but it obviously failed to
do was like show that like powerful
successful women can be friends and
she's like I've learned a lot about
female friendships and then she was like
an you know what like there's not gonna
be one pop star that in the world like
everyone's killing it and then she named
like very specifically named a certain
amount of pop star she said she said
Rihanna
she said Beyonce people are always
putting her beyond against each other
but her Beyonce probably actually really
like each other because they both hate
Kanye like people are always pitting
Beyonce Taylor against each other when
in reality Taylor and JC are friends
they were at a birthday party together I
remember like okay they're friends she
said Rihanna Katy Perry ariana grande
Beyonce I think that was it I think that
was it yeah okay it was just interesting
who she decided to say you know because
yeah it's like so many but it's kind of
the same people that you haven't that
you need to calm down but yes and
there's you are like the people yeah
yeah like there's no other like popstar
that should be up there
you know here's the next one that's
getting up to that level let me think
it's not gonna be who's okay P palsy oh
I actually it looks like it's gonna
the next icon like she has so many hits
under her belt whereas one day I'll just
look back and be like oh my God all
these Halsey songs he does it very
quietly yeah like there are people who
are shocked to pop start I'm like do a
lipeh love her but she doesn't know I
really do and like she's like people are
like I can't do a live because she's
also huge in Europe but at the end of
the day she's been around for one year
yeah you know and she has like three
hits ya know and like Halsey is just
quietly working her ass off we're never
huh and she's showing up to like she's
doing all the legwork like she was to
every [ __ ] award show and she like
serves looks and she like thirsts out
while also like being fun hugely
successful and I think like really rich
remember what she did on SNL painting
singing dancing right yeah she hasn't
stopped she really doesn't actually I
admire her work ethic I think she I mean
obviously she's successful and she's one
to watch in the sense that like she is
the next she's the next person who's
gonna ascend to that tier I actually
think that's a great call thank you yeah
I thought you wouldn't a like bebe Rexha
I'm like no oh she also said Lady gaga
oh yes there too yeah okay I'm glad we
got to talk about that yeah me too so
now it is time to deliver the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast before we do that to
mention what time is Nick coming just so
I know what time we have to code 11:50
okay it's time and Ivan no I've had a
crazy morning with all my caffeine but I
need to talk to you about something you
know I always talk about how I have the
inability to drink water yeah like it's
just something I'm not capable of and
I've managed to survive 25 years without
ever drinking water mm-hmm so we have a
new brand sponsor that I think was
literally the brand was created for you
just for me it's called circle spelled
Cir kul they deliver water your way
sometimes drinking water can be
challenging I hear that but circles here
to help you can enjoy the health
benefits of drinking more water with the
satisfaction of tasty flavors circles
mission is to make drinking water
convenient delicious and fun so you can
feel good about what you drink so what
is circle it's a convenient water bottle
and flavor cartridge system that aims to
help everyone consume more water in a
completely customizable way you can get
the perfect amount of flavor and healthy
ingredients into your water thanks to
the serger flavor dial
you'll never be disappointed with the
lack of flavor ever again with over 30
natural flavors there are plenty of
options for you to fall in love with
never loved heavy bottles or cans water
sorry I can't breathe never lug heavy
bottles and cans of soda water or sports
drinks
from the story again one circle flavor
cartridge can give me more than six
bottles of water for your new favorite
trick so it's helping you stay hydrated
it's cutting costs and cutting you know
running from the carnival to the front
door like a million times for the
million bags of groceries saves money
you can cut back on the overly sugary
beverage it overly sugary beverages and
sodas and replace him with circle so you
can keep away the calories without
sacrificing flavor all of circles
flavors are sugared free and zero
calories they contain no artificial
colors or flavors and are packaged with
healthy ingredients we know we should be
drinking more water and for the hardest
part about drinking water is the flavour
because no one talks about how
absolutely disgusting water is so that's
why we're excited about our new sponsor
circle it makes drinking water more
convenient fun and delicious
our entire family really does love it
tons of variety it's very convenient
saves you money right now you can get
your own circle bottle plus two flavor
cartridges for just $5 by going to
drinks circle comm slash toast and use
our code toast
that's drink circle Cir kul comm slash
toast and the code toasts to get your
circle bottle and to drink cartridges
for just $5 new sponsor one in which I'm
truly excited about and feel as though
I'm the target demo and me too because I
like try to drink a lot of water but
it's like not successful and I need to
switch it up and I love circles and
we're discussing and I guess water it's
discussing okay first story pretty
[ __ ] spooky stuff if you ask me
massage therapist who accused Kevin
Spacey of sexual assault dies why what
why I just heard she was suing him for
60 million dollars right
no that's Kevin Hart Kevin Spacey uh I
think it took Kevin Hart I I know I
could have sworn you said Kevin are okay
wait sorry start again you have this
recorded surely a man will tell us in
the comments yes so keep going the
massage therapist who sued Kevin Spacey
for sexual assault has died according to
court records
lawyers for Spacey filed quote a notice
of statement noting plaintiffs death in
the federal case on Tuesday they said
they were informed on September 11th
that the masseur had recently passed
quote no further information or details
have been given to mr. Fowler's counsel
the plaintiff's counsel stated they
intended to notify the court with
additional information at an appropriate
time in the future the filing said
referring to Spacey by his real name
Kevin Fowler another
the massage therapist Georgia Fowler's
dad I'm not sure the massage chair
has she filed his suit as an anonymous
John Doe has claimed he was attacked by
the American Beauty actor two years ago
during a massage session in Malibu wait
that's so crazy also I didn't know that
I didn't know about this particular
allegation against him I knew about the
one in Nantucket yeah but this sounds
very similar to that John Travolta thing
did the masseuse die no no but he would
have masseuses
die even mo Sousa this is different
cities that come to his hotel room and
they would always have to be male and
one of them spoke up about like the
[ __ ] weirdness that was John Travolta
so very weird it's still alive how old
was the masseur the ASA John Doe we
don't know I actually got a massage
yesterday unrelated it was [ __ ]
amazing except Ben was snoring the whole
time and I heard him that is he kept
waking me up would you recommend the spa
you know I'm so glad you asked that
so me and Ben loved massages yesterday
was our anniversary so I took the second
half of the day off we got massages we
went to lunch went to dinner and we have
been waiting to go to the Four Seasons
spot because it's so expensive and it's
like we can't just go I'm like a regular
Sunday like we go to the nail place and
get our back struck but we're like we're
gonna save it so it's our anniversary we
splurged now I have to express my
disappointment in the facilities like
first of all the spot was seven floors
underground seven okay and it was a gym
like it was just so small so tiny like
it was not swanky at all does that ever
freak you out when you're so far
underground like you might be like in a
nice place but you're like if you looked
at this from like a city view yep you're
just in the great so I got the Wi-Fi and
then I was trying to myself feel better
by saying if there was a bomb like I
guess we would survive yeah that's true
that was the small silver lining but I
was just really like disappointed there
was construction going on that I heard
during my massage it was literally the
morning toast it was the most expensive
massage I've ever had the massage was
amazing so it really made up for it but
like the facilities and just the
ambience was not it Four Seasons so I
just I wanted to warn anyone who was
like oh I'm gonna splurge - don't go
somewhere else I just don't think we
need to be building seven feet
underground do you spend enough time
there an eternity a great and like this
Wow dark
wow this nominee
you know let's filled up well we are and
you know what soon there's gonna be no
more sunlight so we're is that a fact
people are talking about that is the
fact that I heard from an unreliable
source named Danny Hendler but um she
makes a lot of said it says it doesn't
seem unsure like at the rate that
they're building in New York in a few
years there will be no more like
sunlight well there will be Sun but it
just won't come down to the streets
because it'll be launched by the
building yes Wow crazy it already is
right now like you tried doing a photo
shoot in the streets of New York like
you get good light anywhere what our
influencers gonna do I what are they
doing now that's why everyone like who's
a blogger in New York like their
pictures are so like right training yeah
yeah it's so pretend like it's an
aesthetic choice but it's really the
weather yeah no it's really the building
heights so true it's so hard to have
jackieo flow in New York like as someone
who's trying as someone as the
co-founder that's why I only post when I
leave the city so it's really what my
Instagram is I get so back to this or
she's dead late is so bad that's why you
don't post in the city just like because
like it was a man or what man because he
was man on man crime and now he's dead
and I just think that it's [ __ ]
spooky as hell and there's no details
about the death one this person was a
John Doe and to like we only know about
it through the courts so we don't know
any information whether it is a spooky
death or not maybe this person had a
terminal illness right or maybe this
person was 97 you know right Kevin
Spacey's been around molesting people
for a very long time yeah I don't think
Kevin Spacey discriminates like these on
each nobody either um actually he does
like him yeah he likes em young yeah but
so there's no way of knowing so I'm just
gonna consider this I'm gonna file this
under spooky eye but I can't imagine
that Kevin Spacey took out a man but no
I mean like tailed a man killed a man
but not only that he would think that
nobody would think it was him you know
what I mean he'll it'll be a little too
obvious so doing peep I think what
happened to Kevin Spacey is you know
he's in seclusion he's reading about
Jeffrey Epstein and how they got away
with murdering him and he was like
that's the answer
murder murder he was inspired yeah yeah
but I do think like do I think Kevin
Spacey is capable of killing his accuser
yes so I think him and his team are that
[ __ ] stupid that like nobody would
point the finger at them in the middle
of a trial no I don't know now trials
over look at Jeffrey Epstein
if I'm I can't he's dead if I'm a serial
predator I'm
turn into murder next yeah I guess when
you're like molesting young children
your moral compass isn't really on fleek
right it's interesting yeah yeah
so also I think we need to catch up with
empty and see what he thinks
yes and well Margaret told us and he's
back on Instagram so we gotta I know
Andy has literally changed my life with
this bit of gossip about Kourtney
Kardashian and redhead and then I saw an
Arnie - about Khloe Kourtney fighting
fighting over Brad and while I love
Khloe I love her so much and like you
would think I want her to be with Brad
we hate Kourtney yeah but it's like too
perfect I think Whitney's the woman for
him me too
you know and I think more importantly I
think Brad is the man for her yeah and
it's like for so many reasons first of
all Brad and Scott look alike so like
he's her type and like honestly Scott is
so happy and he's totally one I know
it's not a competition
he totally wants totally won attend
Corey new bread the only person that
could beat what Scott and Sophia have
his practice reppin truly and like
Kourtney really is you know like a mom
she prioritizes that I think Brad Pitt
like really is a dad it's like 75
children right and now all the children
can play together they're also like Brad
I don't know if he's drinking right now
but he was like struggling with drinking
and addiction but like Kourtney's used
to that with Scott so like I feel like
she would give him like a very long
leash and Kourtney is not like a big
party girl none of the girls really are
but like they she they're making
something good or Celine's but she would
also be understanding yeah because she
has experience and then they would go to
church every Sunday but she already goes
to like I'm just I'm feeling like Brad
Pitt needs to move into her house like
yesterday ya know a hundred percent I
think her house probably like smells so
good and she's got that humanitarian
house smell yeah I think it's a good
smell sorry fake humanitarian house
smell yeah Oh to fake humana came with
like the consistent one-liner she's
turning into a real housewife how they
all have like go to sleep together it's
making yeah
Kim has you [ __ ] lunatic the least
interesting to look at fake humanitarian
hell like she's really turning out
one-liners she needs to make merch yeah
yes she did but now her merch are her
skins yes which did you get the new
skins we were supposed to be delivered
here but I'm not seeing them so I'm
gonna have to go seek them out you're
ringing in where I'm a [ __ ] obsessive
the skins that I already have jacking me
too but you are going to die from this
okay so it's called the fits everyone
collection they claim that
this undie like big on D grand my panty
song bralette and banjo Brock claim to
fit once extra extra small to 4x and I
got this [ __ ] pair of underwear and
I'm like is this [ __ ] kidding they were
tiny I'm one of them been wearing that
for 24 hours they're so stretchy they
covered my entire Fupa it feels like I'm
not wearing underwear they're so thin
the material stretches so much and then
I put on the bra and I was like there is
no way this bra is gonna fit my jugs
that's how I felt when they put up that
little bra yeah it's tiny
it's amazing no the material is
literally like Elon Musk levels NASA
asked for her money is she's got to be
like patenting this type of material
yeah I've never experienced it before
I'm but my body is really enjoying it
and now I need to find my second
delivery because they sent us more skins
because we're too skinny fluencies we
are skin fluent sirs for damn sure
okay next up a little more fun news
after a spooky death lizzo accuses
postmates driver of stealing her food
when you first lizzo accused oh my god
no what did someone do to Liz oh no it's
worse quote she's lucky I don't fight no
more
Liz o has a complaint to file with post
maids on Monday the 31 year old singer
tweeted at the food delivery service
alleging that one of their couriers had
stolen the food she ordered hey at post
mates this girl Tiffany W stole my food
she wrote in a sense related to them she
put his goats baked oh yeah and then um
post mates responded to Liz oh and I
hope that this injustice is corrected
honestly I feel that one time one time I
order from a kosher restaurant downtown
and they didn't have delivery so I
placed a pickup order and then I sent an
uber rush which no longer exists but it
was an uber messenger it's like a very
expensive stupid way to get my food and
that's how fat I am and the person
picked it up drove ten bucks
threw it out and cancelled the ride and
I was like I didn't feel a mignon in
there I was like are you [ __ ] kidding
me I was furious and honestly like in
that moment like you're waiting for food
and it doesn't come and it's like
someone else's fault like the fury the
you just seemed red yeah and nobody
cares like about how hungry you are you
know no 100%
like the timing of when you order your
food it's like okay I order it 40
minutes before I'm about to collapse so
if it doesn't come and then it usually
like it takes an hour and then sit an
hour to end up with not food ya know to
end up back at square one it's like I
don't even have the strength to order no
no at that point like I'm getting up I'm
going to Germany that I'm eating a
kick-up yeah what was supposed mates
response yeah um they said hi we're
sorry to hear you've had a less than
satisfactory experience on our app would
you mind damming the email address
linked to your account so we can look
further into this for you honestly it
was a real missed opportunity yeah host
mates they could have been like you know
sorry your delivery wasn't good as hell
yeah oh yeah yeah yes line sinker hook
line sinker low-hanging fruit
yeah no this could've been real like PR
moment for them but obviously whoever
was running the Twitter that day is a
big fat failure yes ed you know
Liz's real name Elizabeth what lizard
Melissa Jefferson wow that's just like
such an all night high school with her
and I guess maybe came from Melissa
lissa video yeah it would mean more
tensive her name was Elizabeth Edmund
make more sense of her name was lizard
honestly we make more sense if her name
was Elizabeth okay are you ready for our
next story we're cruising along here we
are crew
what's that Nellie song with it with a
cruise mania song you make me wanna roll
my windows down and cruise did you watch
you knew James Charles video I know you
didn't Jackie but Margaret Cimorelli no
were they saying he likes stands
Cimorelli which I love because like so
do I like I mean I think Cimorelli might
be toasters oh I think you're right
Morelli follow each other so Cimorelli
it's Cimorelli
I used to [ __ ] stand them like watch
their YouTube cover of ABC like with the
headbands marco was obsessed with a girl
who weren't bows in her hair and I was
just like obsessed with the fact that
like I could sing better than all of
them and they did it James Charles
YouTube collab where they played like
this harmonizing game they would just
pick a song and start harmonizing and it
was beautiful oh I highly recommend I've
become like such a youtuber lately like
you should really get youtube TV because
well actually you can watch YouTube on
your TV right yeah but it also just like
really like watching stuff on my phone
in bed I hate watching stuff on Mike
I love watching YouTube videos on my TV
it's like a great day for me when like
Kylie comes out with a new video
I mean Kylie like needs to start putting
out more consistent you vlog content
because everyone that I follow puts out
weekly videos every star he just like
did a collab with the Dolan twins I
watch it and then if she wants to be
taken seriously in the YouTube space
it's got to become a weekly endeavor and
to be honest like I think that she can
handle like the one like people film and
edit for her like literally all she has
to do is stand there and be funny yeah
did you watch her Ellen thing no it was
really like which one I watched your
burning questions but yeah [ __ ] I'm so
bored except like that happens like when
a card actually goes on Ellen like
there's so many different headlines that
come out of it I feel like I've seen it
it's like I know just it was so boring
like she would sit there with storm and
she would ask the question and so it was
like who's your favorite sister or
whatever and she would be like stormy
yes she should sister and she would just
repeat the question like she didn't even
answer it honey and all of our answers
were stormy
yeah like asking who's your favorite
sister is seriously the worst I didn't
ask that question I was just like I
forget what the questions whether they
were irrelevant but that's what I was
just trying to make an example got it I
would want to know like what is truly
your favorite lip kit color like what is
Kylie's favorite yeah what's your
favorite product I'd also say like
what's your least favorite how do you
feel that grape soda now what's two
years later what's grape soda that oh
that purple lips yeah okay yeah ocular
freedom I have freedom so please we
remember when she had that green Doody
green one yeah yeah and like she did the
tutorial with Jordan woods like lol oh
also when I was on YouTube I was just
like strolling through content and I
ended up on her pregnancy to our
daughter stormy and Jordan woods is in
that video so much like it actually
sucks that videos ruined yeah the time
capsule oh they can never so shows they
should really read it and just take her
out like who voice your voice like
narrates throughout
yeah this woman's made out with your
uncle snitch s yeah who's no longer your
uncle yeah but like they've got a lot of
aunts and uncles over there they do
they've got a lot of bands yeah you know
yeah uncles are fickle and fleeting yeah
okay next up back to the streaming wars
news you guys it's getting so good for
the consumer I'm telling you this is the
Golden Age of streaming this is a golden
that's what I say you just take
something completely different
well I don't feel confident in the
golden age of something good and right
and streamed MSE Universal announced his
name release date and revival heavy
launch lineup of new streaming service a
NBC Universal continues to pull back the
curtain on it soon to be long streaming
service announced in early to say that
the platform will be named peacock and
will oh I get it
in April 20 20 and now yeah I guess that
means like start okay they just say that
you learned something every day okay I
don't know TV line it's like so elevated
so it's gonna be NBC you also confirm
that it's streamer launch lineup will
include exclusive streaming rights to
reruns of The Office and Parks and
Recreation as well as a ton of fresh
fare including a reboot of
battle-scarred Galactica from mr. robot
and oh sorry from some otter wow this is
like the most elevated article I've ever
tried very deadly okay what I know I
don't know where does up to a ute you
are you had to say like shopping french
in here but what I found to be
interesting is they're doing a revival
of Saved by the Bell starring original
cast members elizabeth Berkley and Mario
Lopez and a revival of punky brewster
with salal moon Frye reprising her 80s
character I'm not gonna lie like none of
this to be honest sounds enticing to me
ya know but I wish they would have I
wish they would have a morning show on
there that streams live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time I think
that's obviously what the NBC format
needs I think that's what the peacock
means yeah me too um peacock is actually
a great name at first I wasn't into it
but now I understand the history and the
significance and I think it's kind of
cute yeah what are you watching oh I'm
watching Netflix oh no I mean I watch
your friends on peacock you know what I
learned something interesting about
Netflix so I realized something that
it's net like it's internet flicks like
internet movies see on the Netflix yes
and then who lives your everyone knew
that but blue is hula hoop
a joke like hello it's who for hula and
Lou for loop hula loop okay we'll just
drown it out yeah um no this is exciting
I mean I'm not like an 80s TV stand so
this stuff doesn't mean anything for me
but I'm excited for the people who are
bound to be excited by this yeah I feel
like they're targeting an ultra demo
they are and like all those Vanderpump
rules kids who went to like the same guy
that 80s thing they're gonna have to
subscribe everything gives free
subscriptions because they are cast
members on an NBC Universal platform
Bravo
yeah your contract should come with a
free login yeah well there's just so
many logins we're gonna have to have
soon later I'm definitely signing up for
HBO max mm-hmm I'm definitely signing on
HBO max is gonna have friends yes that's
why and the Gossip Girl reboots oh yeah
and when I heard some admitted some cool
other things Disney plus 40 plus for
sure sure um I already got pride I
already got Netflix yesterday who's
getting what someone's get Seinfeld
Netflix is getting Seinfeld and then
also there's this new platform that like
everyone's been talking about in the
industry for like 5,000 years called
kwibi
that means it's going nowhere I know and
it's like I just thought something
answer like some big star gotta show
it's like short form content it's like
10 minute episodes of everything um and
I don't know if it's ever gonna come out
I don't like short form content maybe
there we go one day why if it's like I'm
sitting down to watch something I want
it to be long if it's good I want more
of it
right that's my problem with working
moms the episodes are literally 25
minutes and there's only 10 per season I
started working moms when I was hungover
and I was a mistake because I couldn't
like get through it because I've gotten
so much pain so I need to like start on
it it's so yeah I'm sure it is I just
couldn't enjoy it okay so I have to try
girl yesterday Oh what did you think of
Tom I thought it was great me too I
thought we give this fetus into our
recap no I didn't I'm sorry
Wow but that was great and the box at
the end I didn't see that comment I know
and the Maggie Rogers song with you
wheeler elevated yeah and I honestly I
thought that the girl was beautiful and
Sabrina carpenter is just like the
cutest little butt and she was like the
pretty shallow girl but she was so nice
and like a good sister yeah yeah that's
what I liked about it and it's a depth
and the shallow girly depth
yeah and like there's more to just like
pageant queens and
it looks yeah okay this next door I'm
really excited about merriam-webster has
added new more than 530 new words to the
dictionary this year
remember when Mary Ann Westar made the
word of the year justice and gave us
absolutely no credit no justice for yeah
okay some of these words aren't so
[ __ ] stupid vacay is now a word it's
yeah new of the like these aren't new
abbreviations and portmanteaus sesh a
shortening of session is Bo a short
native inspiration fabulosity shut the
[ __ ] up Webster's influence here fatberg
oh that's from younger remember when her
I'm back caught up no no it's last
season when Diana's boyfriend the
plumber has to deal with the fatberg in
the street
remember no or maybe it's Kimmy Schmidt
Titus's no no he's in construction
Diana's boyfriend there was a fat bird
penis on the news and they fell in love
and yes yes yes what the fatberg it's a
large mass of fat and solid waste that
collects in a sewer system oh yeah
so that's like he was a plumber in here
today where I fatberg um solopreneur
a solo entrepreneur well we are a do
Oprah news yeah that'll joke stared
applause okay new words from games and
sports pickleball thanks to Kim
Kardashian 1111 make a wish
what's pickleball it's a newly popular
court sport played with short-handled
paddles and preffer aided plastic ball
so tennis okay um
11 on me make a wish um I wish for
happiness for everyone yeah and lots of
money for me yeah I think it's everyone
kind of money too
yeah um another new word from games and
sports escape room oh yeah um and free
solo now there's new words about race
and identity they to include a single
person whose gender identity is not a
they marry
inclusive is now a word but but I'm
pretty sure was a new sense of the word
has been added allowing an accommodating
people who have historically been
excluded that's weird I feel like I
think I would have been and then the
last definition like that we have word
for a long time yeah
and colorism so those are the new words
about racing identity new words from pop
culture toaster okay oh my god that's
just [ __ ] up that was funny um Beth
still test I talked about this test
before yeah what is it but why is this
have to be in a dictionary like this is
something that you just look to the back
tilt okay so it's like when you watch a
movie or something it has to pass a
Bechdel test which means are there more
than two women in the movie doesn't pass
that and then do the two women talk
about anything other than then okay I
want to to the back so test for the most
recent movie I watched oh girl there
were more than two girls yeah like Kelly
and Sweden carpenter Jody they were more
than two girls yes and then what was the
other do they have like conversations
that don't revolve around men yeah they
were talking a lot about her insecurity
but it is a lot of men I know it kind of
didn't pass the Bechdel agent the
technical definition is refers to a set
of criteria used to evaluate a movie or
other work of fiction on the basis of
its inclusion and representation of
female characters but like it definitely
included and represented team of how our
characters it was all female characters
mostly like it was 75 percent female
character I would say it's 50 percent no
but we only had those two boys really
like Dunkleman and snipper snipper okay
her dad John her job is so cute I think
it definitely passes the Bechdel test
because it's more women than them in the
film I don't know if that's a criteria
but it feels like it should be if you
guys are pretty even it sounds like four
and four
give me another movie um okay I just
where's definitely past that I feel sure
yeah wait I like never watch movies
whatever watch most recently I'm just
gonna pick something random Benjamin
Button okay honestly there's like no
women there's just that one girl there's
no head and I'm pretty sure that's it
there's no way they didn't talk about
anything except for his illness so it
doesn't pass okay wait new words for pop
culture stinger which is the name for
the short scene that appears during or
after after the closing credits or of a
movie oh my god we needed a word for
that I love the stinger from where the
Miller's where they do like bloopers and
stuff but then they are also singing
along in the car to different songs and
then they play I'll be there for you Oh
with Jennifer Aniston yeah
shameless has a stinger at the end of
every episode and you can miss it it
sometimes important
that's like imagine Harrison is senior
that's right
no yes no they don't yes they do every
time it goes to the credit and then it's
like a five-second thing I know cuz I
always wait for ya but it doesn't go to
the credits it goes to like just created
by but it says like you see like
directed by like it's just two names
that's what yeah I yeah I guess I guess
wait there's some more interesting ones
like we're gonna learn some new words
today coulrophobia meaning an abnormal
fear of clowns I thought they already
had a way to go for clown but this yeah
like an abnormal fear is there a normal
fear I think everyone's fearful of class
I don't understand the clown
fair enough fulness and I'm not afraid
of them no um same but I think there's
like more clowns than ever because of my
Pennywise and stuff so people are even
scared of clowns oh and it and it ok new
words from psychology at Fantasia the
inability to form mental images that
would suck that sucks
um autogenic training a cell relaxation
you guys just got the cutest 'i'm from
raider us from Gregg Sulkin group to me
a been happy anniversary
wow that's really oh my god I [ __ ]
love him that's really original nails
beautiful autogenic training a self
relaxation technique that involves
repeating calming statements to yourself
I need you to do that that's what you do
before your show but they're not calming
yes they are they're hype up there yeah
because if I'm too calm I can't I'm not
funny
you know ooh new words from business and
finance pain point that's something that
people say in in biz ok are consistent
or a recurring problem like this is in
the console yeah dress and haircut a new
sense was added meaning a reduction in
the value of an asset oh so like we took
a real haircut last month I was talking
out in the McKenzie file yeah new okay
then there's new words from linguistics
that like honestly this is boring like
merriam-webster should not make up new
words just putting two words I know and
now there's an entry for dad joke yeah
that's not what the dictionary is for
like this is like urban dictionary right
they're trying to keep up honestly I
think urban dictionary definitely took a
hit to merriam-webster's like Internet
I think Merriam Webster's a little
thirsty for sure they're always on
Twitter like getting involved in like
celebrity drama it's actually really
[ __ ] it's like you're late
like that if you're not gonna be like
non-biased who is that's why I ship
dictionary calm totally merriam-webster
is too elitist and thinks they're [ __ ]
does tank yeah we needed like a new just
dictionary we need a new dictionary with
just like one word for exact like pain
point is something that we say we put
two words together to reflect something
that's happening doesn't mean it needs
an entry in a dictionary
oh is this a new entry in the dictionary
ShoeDazzle think so is that with me
dazzle them with your shoe dazzle shoes
in clothes that's exactly what it is
after you take a super quick 60 second
style quiz you will receive a
personalized showroom of pieces
specifically catered towards your unique
style it shoe dazzle is taking the
guesswork out of what styles are best
suitable for you with just a few clicks
shoe dazzle is doing all the homework
for you you can make sure to enter your
email address for you to take the style
quiz as you'll receive exclusive monthly
discounts and get the inside scoop about
new collections that haven't been
released yet shoot as the biggest
challenge is when hosts cannot finish
the ad oh my god I'm sorry and a
selection it's the coffee it's making me
all be sure to get your favorite
products and they're coming out with a
ton of like really cool collabs with
like influencers and just like people
that I appreciate so I'm appreciating
like the selection and the curation with
their partners you know it's fashion at
an irresistible price it's on-trend it's
chic exclusive impulsive and extroverted
for any fashion forward women who love
fashion especially shoes it's great for
trying something new or experimenting
with your look it's designed for any
women any woman classic edgy feminine
glam boho it's funny I was actually
looking at the selection the other day
and I was like seeing that's a Jackie
shoe that's a Claudia shoe like buckles
and black me cleany and bows Jackie I
just got my shoe dazzle package I got
three pairs of shoes one pair of like
white combat boots that I'm so excited
to be rocking this fall within our
tunnel maple they sent and here's our
shoe dazzle works you take a quick style
quiz for a personalized house
personalized outfit recommendation you
could shop over a thousand different
styles and you could check out as a
guest or become a VIP and VIP perks are
30 to 50% off regular prices plus free
shipping on orders over $39 and there's
no commitment to order monthly as a VIP
shoot
a great company and I think you guys
should all get on board if you're ready
to upgrade your seasonal wardrobe with
affordable trending shoes and staple
pieces then you must check out shoe
dazzle get your first shoe dazzle style
for as low as $10 as a VIP that's $75
off your first item with our special
link shoe dazzle comm slash toast use
that link to take advantage of the steel
again that's shoe dazzle dot-com slush
toast to get your first style for as low
as $10 as a VIP you can also get free
shipping on orders of $39 and there's
absolutely no commitment when you
purchase your first order make sure you
enter your email address when you take
the style quiz as you'll receive
exclusive discounts and the inside scoop
about new collections that haven't been
released yet go to shoe dazzle comm
slash toasts terms and conditions
obviously apply obviously vid the final
story a little food news yeah I'm sorry
little a little food news Pizza Hut and
Kellogg are two partner to create
stuffed cheese it pizza no way pizza
hide a new Kellogg cheese its Kellogg
owns like a bill like a million brands
like differently got it Pizza Hut has
pizzas for meat lovers cheeseburgers and
veggie lovers now the Yum Brands chain
even has one for cheese at lovers the
pizza chain is partnering with Kellogg
to launch the stuffed cheese at Pizza on
Tuesday the limited time menu item
includes four large squares with a crust
infused with the sharp cheddar flavor of
cheez-its and step with either cheese or
pepperoni and cheese a marinara dipping
sauce comes on the side whatever sauce
they have cheese filled crust but that's
not pizza that's like another that's
Domino's Little Caesars yet cheesy crust
exists but now this is like cheese it
flavored cheesy crust do you know what I
feel like this isn't necessary I don't
think there's like a huge fandom of
cheese at flavor lovers you know what I
mean like yeah and it's like it's not
like the most popular snack in the world
it seems really honest I'm getting like
easy cheese stuffing yeah yeah this is
like truly artery-clogging at its finest
yeah I don't I don't support this I love
when two of my favorite brands collab
um but they say this is kind of like
don't call me angel like with Miley
Ariana and Lana Del Rey to individually
think you want it but you don't know
it's a giving people but they don't
really need or want yeah this is
discussing it was this or is good for
this is America's obesity problem at its
finest like the most unnecessary brand
CLAB ever yeah I completely I'm sorry
Brad collab I completely agree and yeah
but now I do want a piece of pizza yeah
where do you guys think is the best
pizza from like national chains so that
includes like Domino's Pizza Hut Little
Caesars what does another like national
cheap pop Jon's I say Domino's I say
Domino's to accept it smells bad okay
I love how it tastes but I hate how it
smells I like all the like supporting
acts abdominus pizza like their desserts
their chicken fingers when I drag
support their actual pizza it's like
thick and like well the first one is
amazing Oh amazing have you never had it
either
no it's Domino's nobody it just tastes
better it's not about even being thin
I put the thin and thin crust we did
great pizza for lunch yesterday yeah we
did yeah enjoy Rosso he just makes so
hungry yeah it's like when you're when
you're when you're so hungry it's like
you're in the desert and then you get a
piece of pizza even it's bad it's like a
mirage you know it's [ __ ] delicious
no but like even bad Pisa isn't that
like a saying but I just understood why
the Mirage Hotel was called the Mirage
cuz there's it's like so beautiful it's
a mirage
yeah we're like you're so [ __ ] up
you're in a mirage oh that actually
makes more sense yeah um that's like a
there's a saying about bad pizza it's
like bad sex it's like it still tastes
so good yeah um cpk California Pizza
Kitchen did you consider that out no no
and they're not there Pizza isn't what
brings me in no it's their kids mac and
cheese their large sodas except
Tricolore a salad it's an off-the-menu
salad it's a delicious salad which you
don't say often that comes on a pizza
crust that's like a cracker and it's the
better lettuce and the lettuce wraps
like my kind of meal or restaurant is
somewhere where I could be thin or not
saying yeah I think with the try Cory
Pizza it's like I could just eat the
salad in me thin I could eat one
lisent the crust didn't be lesson or I
could eat the whole [ __ ] thing and
have a great day
so I'm just like when there's different
levels we need to do a follow-up
investigation the very last California
Pizza Kitchen location in the city
closed down at the end of last year and
we went on the very last day right if
we're can toast right before you toast
yet made us so late because we had like
a three-hour lunch there and vo was
there Thea was there and the waiter told
us that they will be popping up in a new
logo the manager told us yeah I mean
they will be popping up at a new
location in the next year and I just
think we need to further investigate
because I would like to be at the grand
opening meeting right now yeah he was
telling him how I was holding on to hope
too he said no will open back up like
he's he won't let it go either yeah cuz
he stands the franchise as much as me
does he Sanchez's yeah I mean it's his
life more than it's ours
I just we went from having a plethora of
California Pizza Kitchen locations in
the city member that want by
Bloomingdale's that was [ __ ] what was
it 10,000 square feet it was huge two
floors beautiful connected to Dylan's
Candy Bar ah a dream went out of
business then we had to go downtown to
30th and park alright not as good but
we're still happy about it I used to
intern around the corner at lunch share
every day then that one goes out of
business and now we're left with what
nothing we got to drive to New Jersey
we're left with nothing
nothing and I just did some research and
there's nothing no but at least there's
500 blue Mercury's yeah oh yeah no and
you know there's no mercury I just want
to say is the next Mattress Firm they
are everywhere they're everywhere
they're in the Hamptons they're in New
York they're more popular there's one
[ __ ] alte in the city and there's
literally 30 blue mercury they are on
every single corner they're opening up
more and it's like yeah they're good but
like I don't I don't think it's like top
my top choice
no and it's honestly it's not great
they're so [ __ ] pretentious in there
I was in the Hamptons and I didn't bring
chapstick with me and I was in town and
getting manicure and I'm like okay I
need chapstick and I was right next to a
blue mercury so I do a chapstick and she
was like we have a lip balm and I'm like
yeah the same [ __ ] thing I'll take it
it was like literally lemare shake it's
$30 I'm like okay divide it yet do you
know where it is now I don't
yeah but the loose chapstick who spends
$30 on a chapstick she was so like she's
so tall you know so I don't think like I
mean I'm sure there's people who like
love you more blue mercury and actually
I do enjoy blue mercury but they don't
have every single brand of makeup they
don't have everything that I likes like
I don't think it's like has such a cult
following that there you need to be over
ain't opening up on every block no they
only
fancy [ __ ] do they even carry NARS yes
they do
yeah I think you selects or so ours is
like the lowest I'm Brad for them like
they they carry hourglass which I'm
Michael I is the worst [ __ ] bread and
it's so [ __ ] expensive and I won't go
in there ever since
on our corner and they have la mayor
there and they also have like tiny tiny
samples that you could just like throw a
million in your person like not active
to buy lemare and Olivia was like
running a Ponzi scheme and she actually
got in trouble no it's not you have to
like make your own sample so it's
actually a really dangerous business
yeah it's worth it though because the
mare is everything um we're gonna recap
the bachelor on the snatcher let's talk
about it a little and also I didn't have
the time to watch your house in Orange
County because it was a three-hour
[ __ ] bachelor in paradise
and it was my anniversary so I don't
watch Real Housewives of Orange County
crate will save a lot of it for the
snack sure but I just want to hear
everyone's thoughts on the final
remaining couple and where Nicole and
clay we didn't even get to hear from
them and they broke up and everyone was
like up on Twitter being like : clay
they're broken up what the [ __ ] to me to
you from that I don't enjoy it they
shoved them down her throat
at least because there's a couple that
really had any friction everyone else is
here right now let us see the chapter
end that is when I the closure so much
time was spent wasted on them during the
show where it's like they were treated
like such a legitimate couple
relationship goals and then it turned
out to all be a farce and Clay's not
ready for [ __ ] so um I don't want him to
waste any more of my time at like he
wasted Nicole's no I actually agree a
Nicole was on Twitter being so [ __ ]
bitter and you know like she if you
watch her this whole season like her
having a boyfriend who like was arguably
one of the hottest guys on the beach and
then at one point there were two guys
fighting over her unless she was the
bachelor and in paradise echo was like
so inflated that I think she really
didn't see that breakup coming and I
don't think she's recovered from the
earth-shattering moment of her fall from
grace yeah yeah speaking of a fall from
grace Blake um Oh hurry yeah like but
they probably edited so much of that
reunion and I loved that they didn't
edit literally everyone telling Brooke
just apologize broaches apologize then
he finally gets to the moment where he's
like gonna apologize he's like I'm sorry
that you're feeling this way I [ __ ]
hate those types of apologies and then
he's on Instagram liking memes about
Caitlyn just being a dick I'm so over
blade he's
learned nothing like what's he wearing a
toupee yes hair plugs 1000% his hair
never looked so dark and full yeah I
don't know about all that
I'm not like up in the hair plug space
but like I think he looks better than he
didn't paradise cuz he was like so like
pathetic
I don't know they knew the new haircut
that really made his hair look his head
like looks square yeah but I swear if
you like he's just embracing his square
head like he's such a good-looking guy
but he's like he's I'm so fed up with
him I thought me like when he was in
Paradise I was like okay you know what
he's going through it like he'll see the
light he'll apologize like everyone can
come back from anything truly and I'm
ready to move on like I'm done with this
but he just keeps making it worse for
himself he has the worst [ __ ]
attitude about everything and he really
doesn't see how he did anything wrong
and like when he was like if I don't
release these text messages then no one
would have known that you were lying
and it's like no that's what the
reunions for like come on the reunion
and then you can clear your name no but
then one [ __ ] smear someone else is
in such a personal private way and it's
such a damaging way just to save your
own face like be a man a man doesn't do
that a man will just take it but I have
a question this is what I was getting
any juice about Margo everyone was
referring to him releasing the text
messages as he him like blowing up
Caitlin's spot and showing that she was
lying
what exactly did those text messages
prove what lie was she tell that she
like wanted it here's like she wasn't
saying that he like yeah he told her
they were obviously in the consensual
relationship to me she embellished but
there's still facts there Mellish was
because she was saying that he
sweet-talked her I think she was
referring to like all the time before
stagecoach yeah and he just wanted it to
me knowing that like Kailyn was the
aggressor when they wanted to talk at
stagecoach who cares but I wouldn't yeah
but I don't like I said before I don't
care about stagecoach but yeah so like I
don't know if it was just edited badly
but then they were when they were like
talk about talking about why Kailyn was
so upset on the beach like if they had
this understanding it's like he showed
up to the beach being the king of
Paradise and pretended like he had never
met her before and like and that is a
shitty [ __ ] feelings yeah like
sentient machine she might have
overreacted but just in that moment she
was feeling like a piece of [ __ ] because
he was talking up
all these girls and basically ignoring
her when they had had like a four month
relationship she did say that she owned
her part in overreacting and she did
apologize for that and what he did was
so much worse and he didn't even
apologize yes like an overreaction on
the bachelor is like not is nothing it's
not crime that's what we do every day
here
yeah bachelor University yeah but like I
don't know really really seeing
someone's drunk sex
that's a [ __ ] crime and everybody's
sorry for it and Blake still on the
reunion is talking about how he's gonna
be perceived and how he's gonna come off
on camera like there are more important
things he's just so shallow and he was
like I had no idea she'd be attacked
like that like blah blah like team how
their team Dean was like dude you
literally commented I know she's gonna
get hate and two other people said that
oh and also I've been saying it all
season but um yoga it's the true [ __ ]
queen of pastic she was on the right
side of history she was only
interjecting when she really like felt
like ethically like she should and I
just love her and people like Blake and
he finally he actually said one thing
that was really smart he's like I'm
sorry that like I live in [ __ ] around
with all these people and that
definitely affected other people's
experience I'm paradise like maybe if I
hadn't taken up so much time with tisha
Kaelin a Christina Caitlyn like if I
hadn't taken about these people science
it would have opened up the floodgates
for more people I have relationships and
and he didn't say it but he's like I
literally was just like a waste of space
there yeah and that's like what on Jenka
was saying she was like she's learned
just left she was like all these people
are like [ __ ] around with the same
three people and there's literally
nobody here for me because everyone's
involved in the stagecoach thing peace
out I'm gone yeah so I was happy that
Blake owned that because that took some
self-awareness to realize he literally
ruined so many people's potential
chances but literally taking like six
people from pat from the 12 person cast
of Paradise and putting them in this
like vortex where no one else could get
in yeah I love Omega I just want to say
that I can't see a time where like I'll
be over the Blake I mean oh be like last
night if we had recorded the Snatcher
last night like I was shaking with anger
I would have said horrible things I'm so
glad that we didn't but yeah I was just
so mad like I got his hands on Kaitlyn's
shoulders like who's who's the next Dean
because that person's head was on her
shoulder studio was it was because she's
just like so frail and I don't know how
she got this reputation for being like
min master manipulator people then she's
like Taylor Swift like puppeteer like no
she's literally
a precious gem and maybe I'm just like
blinded by the fact that I like her so
much I think she's so pretty and like
deserves but I don't see what people see
no me neither
/ ulation who the [ __ ] did she
manipulates also by the you're in the
minority I thought after that Edgar
would be like wow [ __ ] like I went on
Twitter Twitter's always wrong ya know
but even in snatch our nation like
people were upsetting me they're like
Caitlyn's only getting the sympathy
because you know of what she went
through and I actually feel the complete
opposite I'm like this girl gets
absolutely notice laughing considering
the trauma she suffered like the way
people talk about her and treat her like
has to be trend they had no regard for
what she's been through like even with
Blake releasing his sex and you do that
in the context of what she's been
through where it's like every sexual
experience she ever has it's like her
worst thing ever
yeah um I feel like there's absolutely
no like leeway for her whereas people in
saturation we're like she just gets like
you know special treatment because of
what she's been through it's like
actually it's quite the opposite I think
new people are to her give it the trauma
what she's been through
totally that's what I think we will dive
in more on the snaps or anything take
their toes
yeah hidden file will be joining us soon
on the snap sure and that episode will
be up later today so feel free to check
it out make sure you're subscribed to
the snaps are also big announcement if
you have been waiting to get into the
morning trusters Facebook group it's
super hard for us to like we have over
10,000 requests right now like we don't
know who's a real toaster who just wants
to you on The Bachelor so we've decided
that there's no one easier way for you
to get in all you have to do is leave a
podcast for you one we love podcast
reviews into it'll prove that you're a
real toaster write a podcast review make
sure you state your facebook name in
that podcast review and then submit your
application you sell to answer the
questions and answer them honestly but
we will go through this on campus same
membership rules apply if your answer
stink even if you left a podcaster be
like you're not gonna get in look it's
just a white skip the line it's just a
way for us just because the reason why
we're doing this is because Facebook
groups finally you can search people's
names in the member requests up until
now you could not do that so when you
said my friend is a real toaster I want
to get really like no way of finding
that name in ten thousand there was no
way to do that but there's a search
feature there's a search feature so this
is why we are now doing this and it's
really exciting but you still have to
answer the questions in an impressive
way yeah but we will now search your
name if you leave
House review has to be five stars nobody
if you wouldn't leave us five stars why
do you want to be in our Facebook group
right put your name in the in the review
we will the reviews take only 24 to 48
hours to update so give it a few days
but I think this is a good new system of
getting people into the group and making
sure that they're vetted true toasters
yeah no it's going well we have we've
honestly got so many reviews and it's
getting crazy and you have to understand
like a lot of times we'll get a surge of
people wanting to get into the group
because somebody posted some tea we had
on a bachelor ready page and they're not
your toasters and we really want to keep
the environment very toasty very
empowering so it we have to be selective
so and this is taking an extra step but
I think in the end we'll all be better
off and this is just like a great way to
find toasters in the wild pluck them out
and if we see your name being toasty we
will let you in but make sure that you
request to join the group so many people
I was searching their names and they
didn't have requested oh yeah oh my god
you just like took up so much of my time
and my chance and it went nowhere I put
them all on the list though so that
hopefully once they see this they'll
reapply and I can just try get too many
she says yeah with the most yeah thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning shows as a reminder there will
be a new episode of this snatchler up
tonight with Nick Pyle and Nick miles
also gonna be taking my seat tomorrow
co-hosting the toast with Jackie he'll
talk some bachelor there go through the
Fast Five talk about as essential oils
me and Margit will be heading to
Portland for my show tickets available
at girl no job calm I'm also hitting
Seattle which is sold out in Vancouver
which is not also tickets available at
curled no job calm Friday Margo and I
will be podcasting from wherever the
[ __ ] we are so stay tuned for that I
will see you guys physically on Monday
Jackson tomorrow Oh Tuesday oh yeah Oh
Monday yeah Monday damn still in
Vancouver Ben is coming we have to
remind him to get here but he will be
here he has lots of new things to
discuss with the world he watched the
bachelor so you can get his opinion on
it he was asking so many [ __ ]
questions I could have slapped a much
shut up like you didn't want to watch
this whole season you don't get to just
come in now and ask Mike Hale is crying
and that's what we got for you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
morning Tosa millennial Morning Show we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so feel free to
like this video and YouTube give us a
thumbs up subscribe you know what to do
we're also available as a podcast as you
probably know podcast store on iTunes
Spotify stitcher anywhere podcast can be
found
and we can buy
you